*Pewds monching on some Gfuel*
Feeelix...
...FeEeEeEeEeEeLiX...
Hello?
Who's there?
(Deep Voice) You thought you defeated me...
*Pewds choking on that GFuel*
But I have returned stronger than ever...
(Confused Pewds.exe) 🅱-Series?
NO!
IT IS I!
CINNAMONTOASTKEN!
You deleted my System32, you bastard!
I challenge you...
TO THE WORLD'S MOST DANGEROUS GAME!!!
But Ken, that was 3 years ago...
What?!
I've been gone for three years?!
NANI??
Well FINE, Ken, I accept your challenge!
Boo hoo!
Oh, I'm still mad about losing a video game 3 years ago.
It was more than that...
IT WAS EVERYTHING!!!
All my memes, lost forever(NOOOOOOOOOO)
Ahhhh, well well well...
I don't care, little 🅱itch
*Pewds laughs at the imminent demonitization*
F*** you!
I challenge you to a game of rock...
...Paper...
...Scissors.
Uh, well, I'll have you know...
...I am the winning champion...
...of rock, paper, scissors.
Undefeated!
Ken: How could I forget?!
*ken grunts while poods chuckles; wait that came out a little-*
Pewds: Yeah, you forgot that didn't you? Ken: tHrEe yEARs...
*more chuckling from pewds* Ken: THREE LONG YEARS!
Pewds: You forgot for three years; now you will pay again Ken!
The rules are the same.
Whoever wins in rock, paper, scissors, best out of 3
Gets to control the other person's computer for 30 whole seconds
Ken: That's all I need ᇂﮌᇂ)
I've been plotting this out the whole time...
*ding sound* *ding sound* *ding sound*
Pewds: Aw, here we go Round 1!
Pewds: Hmm, what should I pick, huh? *hmm noises from Ken*
Maybe I'll go for scissors! ಠ◡ಠ
Ken: Oh, I know all your moves.
There's no way you're gonna beat me this time. Pewds: Aww, yeah.
Pewds: Aww b- Oh, you made your choice, huh?
*intense screaming from both sides because poods won XD*
*tf are they both doing (. ﾟーﾟ)*
Pewds: You made a grave mistake challenging me, Ken!
Ken: uGH i'M sO sHoOk rIgHT nOw ಥ_ಥ
*poods breathing into his microphone; ken taking off his glasses*
Pewds: ooh, maybe I'll go scissor again, huh?
ʰʰʰᴹᴹᵐᴹᵐᵐ
*poods screaming dammit because he lost (must've laughed); ken rejoicing*
*wHeEzE*
Ken: You did! YESS!
Pewds: Alright, well it's first to 3
so it doesn't even matter-  *in tiny voice*
ᵐᵃʸᵇᵉ ᶦ'ˡˡ ᵈᵒ ˢᶜᶦˢˢᵒʳ ᵃᵍᵃᶦⁿ
Pewds: ᵒᵒᵒᵒᵒᵒᵒ
*ken drinks something nervously*
*slurp*
*master poods won again; sounds of anguish and rejoice*
OnE MOre
one M0re
*Ken agressively coughs*
(Oh) My Gawd
Are you scared Ken
shaking right now
Maybe I will go scissor again
Getting TrIgGeRed
DAMMIT
UGUGUGGGGGGGUGUGGUGUGGUG *constapated ken*
ITS TIED (BOTH OF TENSED AF)
Ken: FUAAAAAAAA
P00ds: Maybe I will do scissor
again
Both: BAHHHH
*chants* come on come on come on *chant ends*
Ken: COme on God
Poods: Come on come on come on god please scissor
Ken: ITS TIME TO ACTIVATE MY TRUMP CARD
Poods: No not the trump card
UGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Ken: Again
*Laughter bursts out*
Poods: Come on
Poods: Do this felix
Poods: You have been waiting for 3 years you can do it godamit(talking to himself)
AHHhhHHhhh
Ken: will be defeated
Poods: I will not be defeated by the likes of your kind
Ken: NOooooooo
Poods: YESSSssss
(Both doing some intense groaning)